i invited 1 000 random minecraft players
and divided them into seven teams each
team will have 24 hours to develop a
civilization and at the end of the 24
hours we're gonna force them all into
war and these seven youtubers are each
gonna take charge of a team good luck
because 30 000 is on the line let's go
let's go let's go team we're in the
middle of the badlands are there any
trees
there's one tree oh god oh no you're
literally screwed on all accounts hey
listen you should be happy you're not
the team in the middle of the ocean
ocean team you're surrounded by all the
other biomes and probably the worst
biome fit how are things going we've
been doing a lot of building we've been
making sure that the defenses are
impenetrable for the most part if you
guys win you earned it i think you
should just try to smooth talk your way
out of war we have now reached the
halfway point and these bases are
starting to look insane sip over you
guys are stacked right now holy crap did
you guys build all this yes sir
nobody's getting in that i feel like you
guys are gonna win now and i've seen
literally nobody else's build so
congratulations
holy crap this is like a castle we got
like multiple inner walls we have a
giant moat i'm glad you guys started
taking the war serious and you built a
giant burger we got we got our own
mysteries burger yeah towards the end
the team started to focus on the defense
for their bases and ice was even big
brain enough to hire five professional
builders why do you have a dragon on top
of your base because we're fired and
dragons spit fire
you're literally on ice i'm definitely
not putting money on ice right now oh my
gosh you guys are literally sitting on
the border waiting we're not messing
around boy we're not messing around
captains this is our final meeting
before the great war is there any last
words you're all dead wow
server begin the challenge pvp is
officially on and if they die they don't
respond each team in the middle their
biomes have a giant slide and if that
giant slide is destroyed they are then
forced to fight for the team that
destroyed it let's go baby let's go
we're breaching planes they're all in
our land right now they're all in our
land oh they're all right here you're
about to run into all of them
oh my gosh bro there's that all-out war
over here there's a whole demon here go
boys i just want to see blood sip what
is going on i got so much adrenaline in
my veins right now jimmy we're going to
take home this dog we're going to take
on this knob go
go yes we're right in there we're right
in there infiltrative you finally made
it to the slime get some hits in
oh plains is dying oh my gosh yellow's
also coming in and purple yellow and
purple everybody's here planes is gonna
die keep going keep going keep going go
red deep
now that jungle has captured the plane's
army badlands saw this as their only
chance to strike before they got too
strong listen up team badlands we are
going to attack team jungle are you
ready
let's go let's go let's go
what
guys southwest got a couple badlanders
coming over from southwest get them
we're defending this badlands is getting
destroyed right now
we're we've got to retreat oh god this
is bad this is bad we need your guys to
come to the jungle
i'm gonna die i'm gonna die
you just walked over there and lost 20
people probably messing with the wrong
team
oh no i think someone jungle is coming
to us
oh jungle's breaching you're getting
raided oh gosh we gotta defend we gotta
defend oh they're breaking through nice
nice nice nice
oh this slime is taking damage oh my god
they're going down oh my gosh they are
all a tank in the slime no i will go
down fighting with the team ah
that lance is gonna fall yes get it oh
now we're out let's go jungle has killed
planes and badlands now ocean your slime
took some damage what happened we've had
some attackers from all teams oh they're
outside swimming i believe oh the
communists aren't eating all right this
is it gentlemen this is it let's go
jungle kill them all make sure to just
hold up the base dude nobody can stop
jungle this is insane ice red is also
attacking ocean you guys are sandwiching
them now is the time okay go go go go go
ice is right outside the entrance
oh snap desert is coming in hot deader's
taking over right now oh my gosh no way
desert this is your time one two three
start taking down
oh the invasion yo this looks insane
ocean show us what you're made of i
believe in you
blue is actually holding them back
really well actually i thought for sure
desert had you guys that's right we're
not giving up that easy
wait deserts getting attacked now come
destroy let's go let's go let's go come
next year come desert come desert
desert's about to die
how did you guys just get absolutely
trashed
okay ocean's about to die this time in
very buddy it's time to go in it's time
to go in hey you just need to land like
two hits on the slime oh they're inside
oh oh forest oh he's going in is he
gonna get it
oh my gosh force at the last second
stole ocean which means forced in jungle
have now both taken two extra armies on
their team we're working together this
is good this is good we're gonna win
this boys yo this looks so epic bro
green's on their way forest is coming
forest is coming get back to the base
now
they're in the trench hole down there
hold down hold down
guys this is do or die
oh they're taking damage they're
whacking your slap guys get in here red
after all you've done come on guys it's
not over to the door
yes kill them all
[Music]
we gotta go go go
let's go baby yeah wudo you're
unstoppable right now communism will
thrive communism always wins that means
all that's left is ice it all comes down
to this all you have to do is take out
ice mcburkin we're like mcloser yeah we
got this baby we gotta go we gotta go we
gotta go 30 grands on the line what's
going through your head i'm going out
i'm attacking i don't even care anymore
dude don't fumble the bag guys let's go
we're ready for it don't let him get up
the trenches guys i'm breaking through
i'm breaking through go go go they're
breaking holes this is the final push go
go we gotta win this oh forest disabled
training if you're not actually fighting
a green person get in here oh you're
taking damage did it hit it yeah oh he's
hitting it 300 hp i'm pretty sure
there's more green people in here than
purple
forest is going to win only 50 health
left
wait you guys are hurting their slime oh
my gosh stand on your slime stand on the
slime block the hitbox mark to hit my
we're gonna kill him we're gonna kill
him oh my gosh we got this he said we
can win he said we can win he said we
can win go go go
we won we won we won we won no way
forest wins you are the leader of green
team which means you just won 30 000
what oh my gosh no way thank you for
watching the video goodbye